hey it's me again I want to create a
video on how to test yourself for
adrenal fatigue again this is not the
definitive diagnosis for adrenal
diseases I'm just teaching you this so
you can get some clues on maybe some
potential weaknesses within your
adrenals but you go to your doctor to
confirm it okay so that said there are
several symptoms that go along with the
adrenal function you can't get to sleep
easily maybe you're exhausted at nine
o'clock and if you don't go to bed
between nine and ten and you miss that
cutoff you start waking up and now you
really have can't get to sleep maybe 11
or 12 and you're just wired and that
takes 90 minutes because you missed the
wave and then you might get up at 2
o'clock you might wake up feeling
exhausted those are symptoms of the
adrenal you're tired during the day
especially an hour after lunch you're
exhausted you need a nap yet at 2
o'clock in the morning you're very wide
awake achy you can call that whatever
you want you can call it plantar
fasciitis that's inflammation of the
feet you can call it fibromyalgia all
that means is you're running out of the
anti inflammatory hormones and your
whole body is a key brain fog hard to
focus non-sequitur go in a room can't
remember why you went in there you know
it's just not clear you're reading a
book it doesn't really go in low
tolerance people are starting to get on
your nerves right you're edgy you you go
into a room and you see something out of
order and your attention focuses in on
only that and not the rest of the room
breathing issues and that has to do with
two things number one going up the
stairs flight of stairs and your your
legs are getting heavier okay
or at night you can't get enough air and
that's a symptom of adrenal because your
pH is actually too alkaline not too
acidic and that you're having breathing
problems okay
sinus the sinus does get congested with
adrenal so that's one thing and you can
get allergies as well decreased libido
is adrenal and lastly Disney dizzy when
you stand
up so let's pretend that you're lying
down like that on a table and then you
late for about three or four minutes and
you take your blood pressure okay and
then you stand up and take the blood
pressure okay that is the test to
measure adrenal function it is called
the Raglan's test so basically you just
check your blood pressure lying down for
you no wait just relax for a few minutes
and then stand up and check your blood
pressure now normal blood pressure is
120 over 80 so let's say it's 120 or 80
and when you stand up this blood
pressure the top number that's called a
systolic that should go up by 6 to 10
points normally with adrenal fatigue it
will go down or it goes excessively to
high so it's a really simple way to
determine your ability to adapt to
gravity stress so now that's how you do
the test but here's the thing let's get
to the purpose of the adrenal and your
adrenal gland your adrenal gland is a
survival gland it actually helps you
cope with stress it helps you adapt your
body to stress standing up is a little
bit of gravity stress and your body will
then adapt and raise the blood pressure
to adapt for that position change
because if you did not adapt to that
gravity stress there won't be enough
blood flow in your brain and you will
pass out
thus the symptom of dizzy when you stand
up too fast ok does it you get that so
that's a good way to see if your body is
adapting another way you could run up
the stairs and if you get out of breath
too fast from a little run up the stairs
we know that's the adrenal issue or
heavy legs some people will get up too
fast and they can even pass out that's
an adrenal weakness because it because
what happens the adrenal gland has an
outside
this is all gland tissue and they're
both on the kidneys and it has an inside
the Drina gland is the only gland that
has two parts and inside and outside the
outside is all gland tissue produces
hormones but the inside is all nerve
tissue I don't know if you knew that so
it's all nerve tissue in there so it has
a kind of a double thing and the nerve
tissue inside the adrenal produces
hormone like messages and they're called
neuro transmitters adrenaline
noradrenaline serotonin dopamine gaba
those are all neurotransmitters and
adrenaline is a stress hormone so
adrenaline is there to help
neurologically activate certain things
like if you being chased by a tiger the
artery has to open up to the heart the
lung has to open up I mean think about
they'll they'll even give people an
EpiPen epinephrine to help them breathe
if they have an allergy they'll even
inject the heart with adrenaline to open
up the blood flow so in other words this
tissue on the inside is part of the
adrenal system of the stress response it
gets your body to adapt to stress and if
you wanted to know the name of that
nervous system I'll just give it to you
it's called the sympathetic nervous
system another name for the sympathetic
nervous system is the flight or fight
mode so you've probably heard that
tossed around but I want to explain what
that means a little bit more if if you
see a lion in the wilderness chase zebra
the lion is attacking he's fighting the
zebra the zebra is flighting is running
away
they're both experiencing flutter fight
just depends on what end of the spectrum
the lion is looking for supper and the
zebra is looking to avoid being supper
and so it's both a stressful situation
one is a starting situation if I don't
eat that animal I'm going to be I'm
going to die it's a survival thing zebra
if I get eaten I won't survive so that's
what flatter fight means and so we all
have the system inside
body but we're not being chased by
Tigers what we're being stressed out is
the news the media other people threaten
financial disasters threatened stresses
losses physical trauma so you have a lot
of other stresses worried that type of
thing that type of stress is equivalent
to physical trauma okay so basically in
a thumbnail sketch if you're suspecting
that your adrenals are fatigued you can
simply just check one test you can just
basically check the blood pressure lying
and standing and seeing if this blood
pressure goes up six to ten points if it
doesn't then we know there's some
weakness within that system there's a
lot of videos I have on what you do
about adrenal fatigue but I wanted to
explain just a way to test it okay now
in this next part I want to show you one
more part or one more thing that happens
with adrenal and a very simple thing you
can do to help with adrenal fatigue so
one of the problems with an a burnt-out
adrenal is that you start excessively
thinking and analyzing everything let me
demonstrate
oh my god how many calories is this oh
gosh my wife is really irritating me
John at work he is just really something
else my videographer is taking way too
long when you're doing this excessive
thinking I know it's hard to turn it off
but really you have to realize what's
happening you're losing or you lost your
space the best thing the easiest thing
that you can do when you're stressed out
is create space what do you do to get
outside go for a walk go for a hike get
out there and just get your attention on
something else and do it for an hour
do it for longer it's very therapeutic
to add more space because what that will
do that will chill out the adrenals
allow you to heal better versus going
into the gym behind the treadmill and
trying to watch that TV screen right
there yeah you worked out but you didn't
get any more space so you really have to
balance out the
the entire day of activities for
something that will just get your
attention going way out there all right
hope that helps see you the next video